each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's a pleasure to introduce Martin
Bircher Martin Bircher is an assistant
professor in the school of Electrical
and Computer Engineering at Cornell
University he got his master and
bachelor degree from ETH in Zurich in
1996 and then it's PhD from the
University of Colorado in Boulder and in
2000 Martin's been working on a number
of areas related multiprocessing data
compression and today's going to talk
about techniques for creating pfaff data
compressors all right Thank You Ben
thank you for being here so this talk is
really about taking ideas from one
domain and applying them to a completely
different domain that they were never
originally meant for and actually making
a significant impact in this new area so
therefore components to this talk first
I'll briefly talk about hardware
architecture value prediction because
that's the domain where I'm going to
take my ideas from then I'll apply them
first to program trace compression where
I essentially take the value predictor
algorithms but I use them in a
compression environment wrote the
prediction environment then i'll talk
about TC gin which is essentially an
application specific code optimizer and
compiler that generates VPC compression
algorithms based on a simple input
language that describes your trace
format and finally i'll talk about FPC
floating point compression algorithm
that again uses value prediction ideas
and also heavily depends on code
optimization for fast performance so I'm
going to focus on two types of data
program execution traces as well as the
results of scientific programs now as
you probably all know program execution
traces are just dynamic logs of what
happened while you execute the program
for example which pcs were touched or
whatever else you want and these are
frequently used to study program and
processor behavior and if you've ever
used traces you're painfully aware of
the biggest downside and that is they
tend to be huge okay just as an example
if you record on average one bite of
information per executed instruction on
a high-end microprocessor you're looking
at a gigabyte of information per second
of CPU time of course you want to trace
more than one second and you probably
have to trace a whole benchmark suite
not just a single application and before
you know it you're in the hundreds of
gigabytes scientific programs also deal
with a lot of data they're used to model
all kinds of physical phenomena weather
forecasting car crashes airplane wing
design you name it somebody's doing it
and they tend to transfer a lot of data
between computers and mass storage
devices on the order of hundreds of
megabytes per second and they also tend
to generate a lot of new data that needs
to be stored away on the order of a
terabyte each day so of course when
you're dealing with such large amounts
of data there's a cost associated to it
with it first of all it may cost you
money to store it away or even to
transfer it if you pay by the bite and
it takes a long time to move the data
from one place to another and of course
it's very well known that data
compression can alleviate all these
problems in particular if you have a
very good compression ratio then you can
shrink the amount of data lot and
therefore save storage as well as
transfer time but you probably don't
just want a high compression ratio you
also want a very fast compression
algorithm to minimize the overhead of
doing the compression and decompression
in fact if your overhead is less than
the time say
because you now have to deal with less
data then you can in fact increase the
throughput even though you added an
extra stage to your system moreover you
probably want a single pass algorithm so
that you can compress the data as it is
being generated and decompress it as you
consume it and that has the benefit that
the original large uncompressed data set
never actually has to exist as a whole
anywhere in the system it's always
compressed and finally at least in the
two domains and I'm looking at you
probably want lossless compression for
program traces your exactly interested
in the outliers etc right not the normal
behavior that you already know so if you
did lossy compression you would exactly
lose those outliers yes yes you could I
suppose that's a different kind of lossy
compression though right and then in the
scientific computing demand you probably
don't want lossless compression because
for example you don't want to los Los
Ely compress up a checkpoint or
something like that because then who
knows what will happen when you have to
bring it back in so that brings me to
value predictors of course you know that
most CPUs don't operate anywhere near
they are theoretical peak performance
and three of the main culprits are cache
misses if you have to go to main memory
that takes so long that the CPU has to
stall because it runs out of things to
do low instruction level parallelism the
CPU may be able to execute for
instructions per cycle but most of the
time you don't have four independent
instructions to run and of course branch
mispredictions now value predictors were
designed to help or alleviate the first
two problems and speed up CPUs in the
process so the idea is very similar to
Brad
prediction except you apply it to
register writing instructions so you try
to predict what value they will generate
and you do that by observing what values
that particular instruction generated in
the past when it was executed and if you
see a pattern you can extrapolate it and
therefore relatively accurately predict
what the instruction will do in the
future if you do that you can increase
your instruction level parallelism
because you can now run producer
consumers together because the consumers
can use the predicted value you don't
have to wait for the producer to finish
first and for the same reason you can
hide some or all of the memory latency
because you can now run your load
instructions along with the dependent
instructions and because value
predictors is supposed to make billions
of predictions per second in Hardware
they have to use very fast and simple
algorithms which will be beneficial for
compression purposes as we'll see so to
show you how simple these algorithms
really are here's the first type of
predictor that's frequently uses the
last end value predictor so it's just a
table where you have n slots for each
instruction modular the table size where
you store the last end results that it
generated so that when you fetch that
instruction again you can read out the
end results and those are your
prediction or if you just want one
prediction you can select one of them in
fact most of the time this is a
predictor only has one entry per line
anyhow so that solves the selection
problem this predictor works reasonably
well actually but you can do better this
is the stripe predictor it works almost
exactly the same way except you store
the differences between consecutive
results that are being generated rather
than the absolute values and in the end
when you make these n difference
predictions you just add them to the
previous result that that instruction
generated to produce your absolute
prediction
now this works a little bit better than
the predictor in the previous slide
because you can predict the same things
differences of zeros that's the last
ninety predictor in the values well
that's the assumption of the model yes
if there is you will find it you'll do
okay if there isn't it'll just be random
numbers but this predictor can predict
values that were never before generated
such as one two three four five you can
predict the six whereas the predictor in
the previous slide can only predict
values that have already been produced
in the past so this predictor is a
little more powerful you can do much
better with a two-level scheme though
and here's the finite context method
predictor of order X and it has two
tables that work almost exactly like the
last value predictor accept the result
coming out of the first table is run
through a hash function to calculate the
index into the second table which will
then give you the predictions and really
what this is is nothing but a hash table
and what you're doing is every time you
have a certain context of X previous
results that were generated you store
away the value that followed that
sequence so the next time any other
instruction goes through that same
sequence of X previously generated
results you can do a table look up and
see ah this is what other instructions
generated next and predicted
correspondingly and in fact if the
tables are large enough and your hash
function is good you can memorize very
long arbitrary sequences of values and
predict them correctly when they repeat
the differential finite context method
predictor again takes us a step further
by predicting and updating with
differences rather than absolute values
kind of like the stride predictor did
relative to the last value predictor so
these predicted strides then have to be
added
to the previously generated result to
give you the final prediction but
otherwise this predictor works exactly
the same way as the one on the previous
slide so these are the four major value
predictors that have been proposed most
of the predictors of variations of these
and then there's maybe one or two other
ones but I'll focus on these for know
it's exactly the problem okay so there
are several issues first of all with
realistic table sizes that you can
implement in hardware and run a core
clock frequencies you can only hope to
get about fifty percent of the
instructions predicted right as a result
the speed up is relatively small
typically less than ten percent for your
average benchmarks you moreover adding
value predictors of course increases
your power consumption and temperature
two things that industry is really
trying to move away from and it adds
complexity it's not trivial to add such
a component and there's currently no cat
tool support for this for example
increasing your cache size is much
simpler because that's supported by the
existing cash cap tools there are no cap
tools for value predictors so those
would have to be created from scratch
which is a big initial hurdle and that
basically as a result for all of these
reasons and possibly others industry has
not really adopted value prediction
however tools with functionality that's
partially
what is it what's the world catch was
like her branch prediction they have
certain intergration fiction mechanism
they drop it same way um I believe so I
mean they have libraries of different
predictors as far as I know be very
surprised associated mention alpena
cactus so so you'd associate Enoch a
something up also for example gamma
structures was his lab sixers vs I'm not
sure if you want the code anyway it
seems that one well I'm sure they use
different cat tools for cash designs for
example then for ALU designs I mean
these are like totally this joint so in
spite of Mike process of manufacturers
not having adopted these ideas I think
the techniques that were developed are
still extremely useful and that's what
the rest of the talk will be about and
the first example is a program trace
compression so again a trace is just a
log of say all the touch pcs or all the
addresses that were loaded from or store
to or the results of all your
multiplication instructions or whatever
else you're interested in there's a lot
of relate at work and in fact there's
even a lot of freely downloadable trace
compressors unfortunately almost all of
them are tied to a specific trace
formats such as De Niro or something
else and if your information that you
want to trace does not fit in that
format you're out of luck you either
have to use a general-purpose compressor
which will probably not compress all
that well or you have to re-implement
whatever trace compression algorithm
people have come up with for your trace
format which of course is error prone
and time intensive and you're probably
not going to do it also most of the
related work focuses on PC and address
traces for historic reasons PC traces
for branch predictor design a dress
traces for memory hierarchy his lines
while those two areas are still very
important I think we've kind of entered
a new era of looking at the actual
values that we operate on these things
are important for significance
compression you may not want to run your
full 64-bit ALU if the two operands are
effectively byte values or say you want
to suppress coherence messages if you
write value to a memory location that's
already in that location and and things
like that okay so we wanted to design a
trace compressor that that works really
well on PC address and and value traces
and really the insight I was having one
day when I was running a trace study and
and and I was annoyed at the size of the
traces and because I was actually
driving assimilated value predicted with
it I realized that the value predicted
effectively what it was doing was
predicting the entries in the trace okay
so I I thought that's interesting maybe
I should try a value predictor based
trace compressor and in fact that works
really well because the value predictors
were designed to predict the types of
information typically find in a cpu
register which happens to also be the
type of information you typically store
in a program trace alright such as pcs
addresses instruction results etc it's
probabilistic there's a certain
probability while into that model right
correct so when a person is storing
traces he really probably wants to have
a log of what the system is actually
doing yes now in this if I were to you
know predict races using this mechanism
there is probably a small probability
which says that the trace entry is
obtained by this prediction mechanics
there is a small chance that it may not
be really recording what the system
design because it's it's predicting
entries yes so of course if the mod is
that you know the model that the you
know the differential the striking model
that is either like the value predictor
if it's not really eat exactly modeling
what the system is actually doing right
then the trace employees may not be
exactly yes however note that i'm i'm
only attempting to predict them i allow
for the possibility that the prediction
is wrong in which case i record that
fact and i fix it up so this is lossless
compression I can regenerate the
original trace exactly bit for bit okay
but you're absolutely right you know
ninety percent of time maybe my
prediction is correct but the other ten
i have to do something okay and here is
actually what i do okay so i take a set
of predictors i try to predict my next
race entry if at least one of the
predictors gets it right then i only
record a short few bit ID specifying
which predictor and nothing else if none
of the predictors get it right i omit a
reserved ID and i also omit the
unpredictable value okay then update all
the predictors and i repeat this
procedure for the next trade centuries
until I've compressed the entire traits
now a decompression proceeds analogously
you read one of these identifiers if
it's the identifier for a predictor you
know that at this point that
corresponding predictor has the value
exactly right so you can just use that
predictors prediction and if the code is
is the reserved extra code you know that
all the predictors are wrong but you
also know the next thing in the input is
the correct value so you can get it from
there and then again you update all the
predictors to make sure that their state
this is exactly the same as it was at
this point in the trace during
compression and you iterate until you
have decompressed the entire trace now
the actual algorithm that we're using is
a little more sophisticated and as
indicated on this slide here
so up on top and blue I have an
uncompressed original trace where each
trace record has two fields a four by PC
field and this eight byte data field so
what I do is I have a set of predictors
for the PC field and a different set of
predictors for the data field so first I
try to predict this pc i'm assuming all
four predictors here get it wrong and
therefore write the reserved code of
zero to this first output stream and i
also record the value that none of the
predictors could guess in the second
stream then I move on I try to predict
the data field with in this example 10
predictors and I'm assuming the last
predictor gets it right so i write this
guy's identification code to the third
stream and nothing to the forest stream
okay so there's a three major
differences from what i described in the
previous slide first of all i have
multiple sets of predictors depending on
how many fields i have in the input
trace second of all I separate the
predictor codes from the unpredictable
values on purpose because what I do with
these streams is I compress them further
with be zipper gzip or whatever you want
and by separating these the streams are
actually much more predictable than then
when I mix these up in almost random
ways and then the output of bees have
been this case is my compressed trace
you can concatenate the four if you want
into a single file but and decompression
is just you know reversing the direction
of the arrows basically ok so this
algorithm like most other algorithms has
a major problem and that is it only
works for traces with four by pcs and
eight by data fields what if you want to
trace a 32-bit architecture with only
four byte data fields well what if you
want to record more than one p
so data for each instruction that's
executed you need to data fields well
you're out of luck okay and that's why I
wrote this tool called TC GN which
automatically generates a VPC compressor
for you based on a very simple trace
format description and as it does that
it also performs application-specific
optimizations which I'll talk a little
bit in a second and it emits the trace
compressors in C source code which you
can then compile on whichever
architecture you want to use it on i'm
going to show you what you need to
specify with TC GN on the example i used
in the previous slide so for by pcs and
eight byte data fields but it'll be
obvious how you would extend it to other
formats so the coding green here is all
you have to write ok there's a zero byte
header because i'm assuming my data
starts right away if if your trace files
start with some magic number or
something that would be the header and
then there's a records with two fields
the first as a 32-bit wide field and the
second one 64 bits wide if you wanted a
third field you just add a third field
if your field sizes are different you
just change the size ok so this is it
not very hard of course TC gin will
generate a workable compressor
decompressor for this format but it'll
probably not perform as well as you
might hope so expert users can actually
specify more things such as which
predictors to use for each field how
many predictions they should make and
what their first and second level table
sizes should be now you can leave any
part of this out if you don't want to
specify it it'll just plug in defaults
for you or you can specify in case
you're wondering how you figure out
what's a good configuration well at the
end of every compression it prints
statistics to the screen that tell you
how often each predictor component was
used so you can take out the ones that
were useless and try a few other ones so
you can do a few rounds of trial in
there and you
you end up with a pretty good
configuration for your type of trace
relatively quickly if you don't like
bzip you can specify any other command
lines for example gzip or cap if you
want nothing or a tool that you wrote
yourself as long as it supports standard
in and standard out you can use it
directly in this way now like I
mentioned TC gen performs several
optimizations on the code the first is
common sub table elimination which is
kind of like common sub-expression
elimination accepted operates on on data
structures rather than instructions so
you may have noticed that the last value
stride and the DFC em predictors they
all have a last value table and other
things so if you use any combination of
these TC GN will only allocate one last
value table and share it among the
predictors likewise all the FCMs and DF
CMS can share can partially share their
first level tables in fact TC GN will
only allocate the the highest order
first level table and all the lower
order predictors can then use whatever
fraction of the table that they need the
next important optimization is a hash
function strengths reduction and common
sub-expression elimination so first of
all the hash functions are computed
incrementally based on the result from
the previous iteration rather than
recalculated from scratch which is much
faster and second of all it's calculated
in an interesting way such that the
intermediate results are exactly the
correct hashes for all the lower order
predictors so those are essentially
obtained for free there are several
other application specific optimizations
including unused parameter elimination
etc and then finally because you met C
code of course you get all the
optimizations that your standard C
compiler provides so on this slide I'm
showing you compression ratio results
for three types of traces from spec CPU
2000 pro
Rams first look I'm sorry BBC right yes
so I'll get to that but VPC for here is
the compiled output of TC gin so the
application-specific of my visions or is
the application bar over there because
trace compressors these optimizations
don't really apply to general programs
merging the tables and you know
computing this hash function yes yes ya
dumb question what kind of trace what
kind of tracy my trace sorry i came in
early um basically a program execution
trace where you record for example pcs
of all the executed instructions or the
memory addresses that were touched like
an instrumentation exactly exactly the
format that you said so line by line
I'll bunch of fuels right Chris
off-screen behavior I assume you're
going to go into other because I
specifically am interested in a
compressor 24 for example executable
content so of the trace at the content
itself oh ok that's it now that's a
different animal we can talk about that
offline i mean i have other compressor
algorithms so here there are three types
of traces PCs and defective addresses of
all the executed store instructions in
the spec CPU 2000 programs this is just
a plain vanilla address trace like
people have been looking at forever then
another address race for all the loads
and stores that Miss in a simulated l1
data cache this address race is much
harder to compress because the l1
filters out a lot of the nice patterns
in the address trace and then you only
see what's left namely what mists in the
cache and finally traces of PC and
loaded values of all load instructions
these are also hard to compress because
loads load all kinds of different things
floating point values in teacher values
character strings bit masks you name it
right I'm showing compression ratio
relative to bpc 44 bzip2 which is just a
general-purpose relatively well
compressing algorithm that has no idea
that we're using traces here the other
five are special purpose trace
compressors so they can't really be used
to compress anything else or it just
doesn't make sense and they all use
bzip2 as a second stage compressor not
just BBC Four so they're sequitur here
which essentially generates a
context-free grammar out of the program
input and compresses it that way this
works really well for pc only traces but
not so well for address traces as you
can see mash is an older address trace
compressor that essentially specifies
the the differences of the current entry
to some base entry and expresses that in
in a bite if it can if you can't it
specifies the full value and that
becomes the new base p dots and
especially p that's too it goes a little
bit further they operate on strides
other's differences between consecutive
values and specify them in however many
bytes they need so there's a Heather
bite that specifies how many bytes will
follow and the header bite also has room
for the most common values so it
compresses that way SBC stream-based
compressor that is a new address
compressor developed at the same time as
VPC and it works by identifying streams
that is a sequence of increasing values
and whenever that same sequence repeats
it's just replaced by an indexing hey
this is the same sequence again and then
VPC for as i said the output of TC gen
and as you can see most of these
algorithms actually don't compress all
that much in the first stage it's really
the post compressor that does most
work but at least in case of VPC for
which by the way compresses worse than
sekret or and Spc in the first stage but
better overall the reason is because VPC
for was designed with the second stage
in mind remember I create these two
streams instead of one exactly because
that helps the second stage and I output
the predictor codes in and bites even
though i don't need eight bits there
aren't that many predictors but bzip
works on by granularity so it's much
better to do that the other algorithms
try to compress as much as they can in
the first stage and as a result
unfortunately obfuscated a lot of the
nice patterns and make it harder for
bzip2 do a good job okay so it's better
to optimize for the full system rather
than optimize each individual component
separately so overall as you can see VPC
for compresses almost twice as well as
the other algorithms on average
certainly not in every single trace on
the address traces SBC gets pretty close
but again the other algorithms are
roughly a factor to worse now looking at
the decompression time now lower is
better we can see that v pc 4 is also
one of the fastest except done on these
two types were on sequiturs a couple
percent faster so not not a big
difference and compression time VPC for
is actually factor two and a half faster
than then all the others and it's except
for a single trace it's the fastest on
every trace that we tried and again you
can see that relatively little time
compared to these others except for
secretary is actually spent in bzip2
even though we send more information to
bzip2 than necessary by making it by
granularity for example but we help bees
it to in turn so much to recognize
patterns that it not only compresses
better but it also operates much faster
okay the significant additional time
that these other things are doing I mean
you know it seems like yeah I mean were
they just not timid or something or no
like I said I think the the major
problem why bzip2 takes so long here is
because really what the other algorithms
tried to do in the first stage is
compress as well as possible and that
totally obfuscates the output and makes
it really hard for B sub-2 to be
effective so these are two has to do a
lot of work to kind of disentangle
what's going on and obviously it's
running time depends on on on the input
and it's apparently not a good format
for it so to summarize these middle two
parts I showed you the VPC algorithm
that's based on unvalued predictor ideas
and they have the highest remaining mean
compression ratio and fastest
compression speed also in the majority
of the trace is not on every trace and
decompression is also the fastest except
for secretory like I said which is a few
percent faster in absolute terms I've
seen compression ratios between 5.8
which is not so bad if you think about
six times smaller trays up to 77,000
which is pretty impressive so there's
this one address trace where on average
we compress 77 kilobytes into a single
bite in terms of throughput on an old
alpha system we get five to forty
megabytes per second decompression speed
and 22 23 megabytes per second
compression speed on a modern pentium 4
system these numbers are about double so
they're faster than a cheap hard disk so
that means it's it's actually quicker to
read a compressed race from the disk and
decompress it in the CPU then reading
the uncompressed trace and finally I've
talked about TC GN
which is this compiler if you will that
compiles your simple trey's description
in to see source code that you can then
compile and run on your system pc jen is
freely available at this URL you can
also get to it from my home page by
clicking on TC GN and it's actually
pretty widely used researchers at MIT
CMU princeton intel colorado um san
diego and a few other places use it as
far as i know and they seem to be pretty
happy with it so the final part of this
talk is floating point data compression
now as i mentioned earlier scientific
programs produced and transfer a lot of
64-bit double precision floating point
data and there's quite a bit of related
work but most of it is on lossy
compression which i'm not focusing on
today and what little work focuses on
lossless compression is typically
concerned with 32-bit single precision
data as is frequently used in games etc
but i'm focusing on 64-bit data and
there are really only two types of work
that I'm familiar with there and one
focus is on on smoothness and data so
they assume that consecutive
floating-point values differ by only a
small amount and the other one exploits
geometry so they know that this the
sequence of data that you're looking at
is actually a linearized form of a 2d or
3d object and they use that information
to compress it better now our approach
is more general purpose on site so
there's a bunch of work at wasi yes oh
that's trivial right because of the way
it's expressed with the mantissa you can
just chop off bits at the end widest I
just find that how
is all that dated oh they don't that's
exactly my point they want lost less use
generally most of the work is lost lossy
and they really want okay the the hard
truth is high performance computing
environments do not use data compression
because there's nothing suitable so far
I hope to change that all this NASA data
yes you hereby it's literally correct
all this stuff coming down from the
space shuttle or whatever from that
writers Explorer right they don't use
data compression on those Street no they
have huge facilities with tapes where it
gets recorded and never looked at
literally okay there's in fact just this
is as an aside okay NASA apparently
download so much data every day that
there is no way they can possibly
analyze it all so what they do is they
store it away and research is all across
the globe they look at all kinds of
things when they find something
interesting I don't know some star
exploded then they'll know what time
that happened they go back to their
archives and they read all the other
data around that time to see whether
there was something interesting to but
two-thirds of the data is never ever
looked at by a human or a program okay
but you never know when you're going to
need it so you store it away so so yeah
we want a compressor that doesn't need
um this I don't know what they do there
because that's that's really a different
domain lossless as well yeah see the
other thing is i was also i was
surprised by that i talked to people
from Lawrence Livermore National Lab and
they basically said look you can't
really make it lossy for several reasons
first of all yeah you don't know what
other people might want to do with the
data second of all a lot of times they
compute certain data and I don't
understand all of this but they then
compute derived information from that
data and they need certain accuracy
guarantees thirdly like I said I mean
program check points etc they have to be
lost less because every bit counts right
and there's other types of data where
they actually reason about the accuracy
of the program they know they wrote the
algorithm in a certain way they know the
properties about I Triple E 754
floating-point operations etc so they
can bound the maximum error so and
that's obviously important for them
otherwise they wouldn't go through this
exercise so clearly they didn't don't
want you to all of a sudden come along
and you know take away from from what
they've done anyhow because of our
success with VPC for trace compression
we figured well you know maybe we can
compress floating point data with that
as well too fortunately this turned out
to be much harder than I expected first
of all floating point values are really
hard to compress okay and the reason is
so I have 13 really cool datasets I
think from all over the world I have
weather satellite data from Europe I
have a simulation of the comet
shoemaker-levy 9 entering Jupiter's
atmosphere from Florida I have let's see
I've data assimilation a code from from
weather forecasting I have brain injury
simulations I have code from messages
from some parallel computational fluid
dynamics code that they sent between the
nodes etc etc so when looking at the
state I found that over half of the
traces over ninety percent of the values
appear exactly once okay that's not a
good starting point for data compression
moreover we really want to compress
these things very quickly because in the
high performance computing environment
and that's the reason why they don't use
compression right now is they will not
add another stage to their processing if
it slows things down okay these systems
are so expensive well you know they'll
just buy a few more terabytes of disk
space they need
so what the only chance you have is if
you can provide real time compression
that is you can compress the data faster
than its being produced and hopefully
actually get a speed up in the process
because now you have to deal with less
data and that's what I'm trying to shoot
for now actually we're sort of in luck
because it turns out you don't have to
precisely predict the values as long as
you get close that should suffice
because then you can just encode the
difference between your prediction and
the actual data which will hopefully be
a small number and you can encode that
with few bits so if you look at the I
Triple E 754 double precision format if
you try to predict the value and you
your clothes then hopefully you'll have
the right sign bit you have the right
exponent bits and the top fume
anticipates will be correct to down here
is the random part okay but if you get
it right then you really only need to
record this part because the rest you
get from the predictor and that's how
you can achieve compression and here is
the actual algorithm up on top again I'm
showing an uncompressed trace it's just
a sequence of double precision value so
this red number here is a hex
representation of some double and what I
do is I try to predict it with two
predictors an FCM and the DFC m I don't
have time to run more than two
predictors okay then I pick the closer
value of the two predictions and I XOR
it with the true value and if the two
values are similar there will be lots of
leading zeros after the XOR because X
returns identical bits into zeros and
it's reversible then I use a leading
zero byte counter not bit byte counter
because that's much faster than bit
counting and I encoded in the following
format I record one bit that tells me
whether I use the left of the right
predictor and three bits to encode the
number of leading zero bytes
and the remaining bites are just emitted
the way they are okay and because of
this for bit field here I actually
always compress pairs of doubles
together because then I can merge the
4-bit fields into a single bite and then
everything is done at the bike
granularity which is much faster than
Big granularity okay note further that
this algorithm was actually totally
co-designed was its implementation okay
I tried a lot of different ideas
different predictors different numbers
of bits and leading bytes bits and
whatnot counters and I only took
whatever I could find a very efficient
implementation for moreover once I've
kind of settled on the algorithm I tried
as many different versions of each
component each predictor the leading 0
by counter etc etc that I could think of
I compile all of them on four different
architectures in four different
compilers I timed them and I looked at
the actual assembly code to see what was
good what was easy for Kampala to
generate efficient code for and this
algorithm is actually the result and to
give you a little more information about
this code design so I focused on the
innermost loop which compresses a block
of data so it takes about 50 c
statements to decompress a pair of
doubles and 70 CE statements to compress
a pair of double so you know it's a
reasonable loop size even after all of
our optimizations this is where 90% of
the execution time is spent so clearly
this loop is the critical loop and
everything else you can forget so the
first thing I did is change the hash
table accesses in the following way so
those are the only ones that cost cache
misses okay and what I do is I always
use the hash table and I immediately
request the next hash and then use the
rest of the loop body to hide the
latency before I actually use
the the value okay second even though
we're compressing floating point data
there's not a single floating point
operation in the entire algorithm I do
everything in the much faster in teacher
domain and there are only two kinds of
slow integer operations namely
multiplication division they don't occur
okay i only have shifts adds subtracts
and logic operations for the entire
algorithm yes let's do this low
operational oh absolutely I mean
compared to add and subtract which takes
one cycle multiplication usually takes
in the order of seven cycles so yes so
it brings up the question about
specialized processes for I mean sure
it's under your name sure angle cycle
and also vector process the other thing
which i think is quite impressive is so
they're 50 to 70 CE statements they
compile in 20 branches okay branches are
obviously slow so it's good to get rid
of them and the reason is that I wrote
the code in such a way that there are
lots of if statements in there okay
don't get me wrong but their bodies are
trivial in the sense that they either
allocate assign a constant to a local
scalar variable or they copy one local
scalar variable into another and all
compilers and all four architectures
that I tried this on can convert that
into conditional loops okay so the
result is a single basic block with over
100 machine instructions okay this is
perfect for scheduling and for exposing
ILP and in fact on the widest machine
where I tried this which is a 19 iam to
which can theoretically run six
instructions per cycle with hash tables
that are small enough to actually fit in
the l1 data cache I get sustained 5.4
instructions executed per cycle for
decompression in 5.1 for compression
which is a
pretty impressive ILP so let me show you
the results ok I'm going to plot the
throughput so higher is better against
the compression ratio down here again
higher is obviously better for several
algorithms on those 13 data sets that I
mentioned earlier so here is bzip2 going
from its fastest mode to slightly slower
but better compressing up to the best
compressing but slowest mode compresses
these traces by a factor of about one
and a half on average it's so slow that
it seems to be hugging the zero line
here gzip as is well known is slightly
faster but doesn't compress as well and
that's exactly what's reflected here now
these two algorithms don't know about
floating point data they just chop them
up into bytes and try to compress them
ok the other four algorithms actually
are specifically designed for floating
point data so here is one by Peter
Lindstrom from Lawrence Livermore this
one tries to take advantage of 2d and 3d
information which we don't have for our
traces which is why it doesn't compress
better but it is actually faster than
gzip which is a little hard to see now
fsd is the algorithm that assumes that
the data is smooth which is not the case
for our traces which is why it doesn't
compress very well at all it is pretty
fast though ok and then here is DF cm
which is our first version which uses
just a single value predictor and it
does not operate on white granularity
which makes it slower it's still faster
than the other algorithms and it
compresses reasonably well I mean only
be zip is really faster and here is the
FPC so this is the algorithm have been
talking about so far obviously much
faster in fact for any given average
compression ratio it's ten to a hundred
times fast
than the other algorithms moreover if
you make the tables really large it does
get slow because of all the cache misses
but it does reach much higher
compression ratios than than the other
algorithms decompression picture looks
almost exactly the same all the numbers
are actually slightly higher so the
throughput is a little bit better for
decompression if you look up on the top
here this is where the predictor tables
fit in the l1 data cache were close to
seven gigabits per second obviously
that's a nice throughput for a compiled
C code running on a general-purpose
machine so to summarize this last part
of the talk I showed you that value
predictors can quickly approximate
scientific data and therefore this can
be used to compress the data as we've
done in the FPC algorithm which gives
you the highest mean compression ratio
again on average not in every single
trace but it does give you the highest
compression and decompression throughput
on every single trace that we've tried
in absolute terms I've seen compression
ratios from 1.02 which is useless to 15
which is pretty good but as we saw in
the previous slides on average it's
under a factor of 2 but you know for a
floating-point this is actually pretty
good because if you think about it if
you generate a terabyte of data per day
saving a few hundred gigabytes every day
it's not so bad okay now in terms of
absolute throughput on this 1.6 agaratz
itanium too we decompress at eight
hundred and forty megabytes per second
and we compress at 680 megabytes per
second that's obviously faster than hard
disks faster than gigabit connections
and if you do the math this amounts to
only 9 machine cycles to decompress a
double or 12 and a half on
average to compress the double now the
interesting thing here is that these are
an average numbers these are the same
for every program because remember the
loop is just a single basic block which
means for compressing and decompressing
a double it always goes through exactly
the same instructions therefore and if
the tables fit in your long cash and the
loads are the only instructions in that
loop body that have variable latency if
they fit in the l1 cache they always hit
so the latency is fixed so therefore the
code runs at exactly the same speed
independent of the data and independent
of the achieve compression ratio which
is very nice because this is the real
time guarantee ok i can tell you upfront
how long it will take to compress your
data I don't care what data you give me
ok so or I mean is an independent of
also the accuracy oh this is lossless
compression so I really but you're
you're you're looking at a difference
right your mat you're you're fitting it
to something oh yeah i mean like i said
i mean it's independent of the
compression ratio however obviously the
output size that you don't have to do
something else with that is dependent on
the compression enters have some max
similar noise and being it up able to
adapt that signal noise and throw away
that extra that's why I'm ordering ok
well I mean this is not really the area
i'm targeting right i'm targeting
high-performance scientific environments
where i'm assuming they currently can
store away to data at maximum rate
already so right yeah i don't know but
but then if you need a guarantee that
you're not going to produce more than a
certain amount of megabytes per second
that's a very different guarantee then
the guarantee that you can process a
certain number of bytes per second
yeah if i take that almost horizontal
part of top of your decompression charm
and extrapolate 20 it looks as if it's
it's cheaper to decompress compressed
data to read the raw data memory that's
so or you can say no no no no that's
impossible right I'm reading my data out
of memory and I do something on it so
clearly if I just read it and didn't do
anything on it yes yeah but I mean on
this slide i'm reading the of a
decompression how far would be just read
data from memory oh I don't know but I'm
sure it's much faster cuz no no I mean
like I said here so it takes so many
cycles to essentially read or write a
double and the itanium to can actually
read and write two doubles per second
per cycle so so clearly that's much much
much higher experiments Iran and you
discussed in the first part of the doc
there is much cheaper to lead compressed
data and decompress it online some hard
disk he's asking from memory
ok so again if you're interested in FPC
the source code is available online at
this URL or from my home page and I
currently only this is very new work I
I'm only aware of one user but the
European Center for medium-range weather
forecasts actually uses an earlier
version of FBC for compressing some of
their satellite data which is kind of
neat is it what is it ok it seems like
there's a lot right there's a lot of
space data that would actually be very
amenable to right I guess the question
be you need a fair amount of horsepower
and actually do this compression so it
may not work in spacecraft for example
to him they do the compression just
because it needs a fast process service
well if you decide to build hardware
that specifically doing this and nothing
else and it doesn't have to be general
purpose I think you could easily do that
was done on an x86 base no this is
itanium to F at X 64x64 or X or 32-bit
64 64-bit x86 architectures itanium to
is not x86 itanium to is a great epic
it's totally different it's a VLIW oh
well but I have results for for pentium
4 AMD yeah i mean the trends are similar
the other machines are slower in
absolute terms but I mean that affects
all the algorithms that the difference
between the difference here is not as
high because here we're running at over
five instructions per cycle all the
other machines don't even support that I
mean they have four three ways
superscalar and that's why I can't
exploit all the parallelism that I have
there which is why the gap is smaller
but it's at least a factor of 2 and all
the machines that I've seen up to a
factor of 10 like I said on this machine
I mean architectures are going
towards including vector processors
inside of it then my guesses will
fundamentally change these processor
speeds I mean the your algorithms be
right if you're doing certain ones like
cumulates in seven bucks seven cycles
which are walk down to ones I mean that
that could on that I Chad that could be
possible looking towards doing things
are you're looking at different
architectures to apply this to at this
point um not right now my goal was to
write a portable piece of C source code
that will almost certainly run well on
just about any architecture that that
you use it on because that's what people
are likely to to use right away if you
do anything else then yeah maybe it'll
be useful in 10 years hey you live in
using conditional moves right do I
doesn't depend on the carry it because
currently things impossible to use a
calculator efficiently on inter
processors no no as far as I know they
all check either a holes 32 or 64-bit
variable 40 or they check like the least
significant bit or something like that
there's no addition in the in the
condition that that would not know
there's no good will you no no no it
depends on the type of comparison if you
compare for equality you don't have a
care so to conclude the entire talk so i
hope i showed you that architecture and
code optimization ideas can be applied
successfully to areas that they weren't
designed for originally and and I've
showed you this on VPC which uses a
softer version of value predictors to to
compress traces TC GN which obviously
uses compilation and code optimization
techniques to automatically generate
trace compressors FPC which again uses
value predictors as their
predict our compression model and
heavily depends on code optimization
mostly on knowing what can efficiently
be compiled and executed on current
existing systems and I guess what I
think is particularly interesting about
this work is that I took ideas from one
domain that wasn't very successful and
turn them into quite successful ideas in
a different domain for which they were
never designed originally and with this
I'd like to thank you all for being here
and NSF and do e and Intel Corporation
for supporting this work any more
questions ya been I guess you know I'm
curious if you thought it all about
these sort of specialized hardware to
support your really quite impressive the
expression because yes i have any more
about it well let me let me tell you
this we currently have a paper under
submission to the data compression
conference that that does the harder
compression of traces program traces I'm
I'm going to California next week to
talk to a company that specializes in
exactly that and I will figure out what
they have to say and and see see where
that you can tell us that companies
right yeah it's called peak stream okay
because interestingly enough Intel also
is now trying to produce a board-level
super 24 korish kinda GPGPU
which would write probably scream of
course but they're also pulling that
into their processors as well as
allowing that under chipsets and there's
not going to be a machine that doesn't
have an accessible GPGPU whether that's
an intel or AMD with ati or something
like that I mean all of them will have
some form of accessible opportunity view
which would I would expect that really
lower some of that yes hopefully well
you know I mean they have super wide but
no no I understand the question is I
mean you have to change your algorithm
if you really want to want to exploit it
which I believe I can but I've said that
many times in the past and they turned
out not to be true so I want to be
careful so you obviously in this
effectively to the low point you may
have you thought about other domains and
you know sort of have cared for it seems
like all a full of people care about
compression for a lot of different kinds
yes let me ask you this what other
domains are there utting pointed an
objection to xml okay so text
compression basically well yeah
interesting to know what what kind of
XML what needs to be compressing is
addition to but and the other one can-
bioinformatic did okay you know gene DNA
sequence ok on the former on text I I
have tried it briefly more as a fun
experiment so because all of my approach
is a lossless so they're guaranteed to
recreate the original data you don't
have to give it a valid trace you can I
Iran I think my dissertation through it
okay it works fine I mean it recreates
it right you don't get better
compression ratios than out of other
tools and it is not faster than other
tools so there's really no point in
using this particular algorithm I'm
talking about TC GN now FPC would work
really not well on text okay as far as
bio informatics data I've actually
downloaded some rat
somes text me for this purpose and I
tried to compress them and that did not
work well at all now they are not highly
compressible with any of the algorithms
I showed you today so you really need I
guess a different set of algorithms
that's specialized for that type of the
main because it's a binary data service
well it's gonna just let scoop it's
alright because before yeah i mean the
instructure a lot like this bullet point
David but it's just really matter of
started figuring no it doesn't see
that's the same well it had some
structure I mean it's not maybe the same
yeah you know it's one of four but no
but there are multiple levels of
structure writers yes that's right
that's right but that's what I'm saying
you need special algorithms that are
aware of this or at least and figure
this out which bees it doesn't right yep
another domain with may be lucrative his
email where every message was every
Bridge message all the way to Adam and
Eve and even compress some of it but if
you know that this is what messages do
and I suspect lots of Venus or doesn't
does not know it yes oh yeah it's got
sure that but for mine I want Lawson
yeah how are you i want it from the
beginning but i want lossy from the
beginning most but i don't want to i
even move I'm kids I'm Kevin Young you
expect impressive I can't hear you I
used to be here with the thread
compressor threat nope hey which is
Rachel internal my ex up to which
essentially is the same thing I see red
compressor on it son toolbox yeah um I
haven't questioned about the former you
know executable code domain yes so I
work on so we compress windows updates
okay so we do not mind rematching work
and you know that's differential
compression right that's not really the
question I have right now but no matter
how much binary patching we do we always
have to have a standalone version with
the update okay so you know something
that's not a patch which is you know
actually you bind
themselves tell me people use them when
they want to you distribute them using
other mechanisms okay so my question
would be some some algo latitude
specifically the pd kode now we have
something a few transforms that we do
that improve some pre compression
transport I mean they're very perilous
wheeler we don't actually do that yet
but things like smashing blocks lock
instructions again greater then
transforming goes away doing some stuff
in diate jumps I flew with anything else
which works well for I haven't really
done any work in this domain I think
there was was there is somebody at
Arizona who published a few things like
in several years ago already this isn't
particularly new work but if i remember
right what they basically do is they
kind of decode the instructions a little
bit they know where the opcode is they
know where the register specifiers are
etc etc and then either they compress
them separately or they rename
effectively so that they get more
patterns that repeat etc and i think
chris fraser used to work here he did
some work in that domain as well so
you're probably more familiar than I am
with with that so I like I said I
haven't personally done everything
anybody the room is looking for a
lucrative opportunity and that's it
especially because you know things like
big service packs no I literally affects
bottom line somebody's paying for all
that writing familiar of code
compression work using echo instructions
Econet structure our calendar he works
at Microsoft's now
he is dumb that some work on for
compression Gazzaniga instructions yeah
well that might be that might stress
raisers work sort of originally so crisp
chris is going actually came up with the
echo instruction I didn't ecco ecco ecco
instruction yeah so that's a ECHL
Santiago but that's assuming your
hardware support how come in the whole
notion of akwa instructions is it it's a
hardware mechanism so thank you all
right